[Music]
kuan trading is an incredibly
interdisciplinary field to be successful
you have to draw upon pure technical
skills in areas like computer science
and mathematics but you also have to
understand markets understand psychology
and you need to be able to bring that
together in a commercial result ai is
necessary for co-op trading because it
is growing exponentially computing power
there is no way for a human being to
process the enormous amounts of data
with the AI for trading nanodegree
program you'll see how artificial
intelligence is changing finance you'll
get hands-on experience analyzing real
data and developing trading strategies
for stock market we worked with world
plot and top finance professionals to
create a world-class learning experience
that can open doors to jobs and finance
you'll analyze financial market data
with predictive models and machine
learning algorithms you'll even use
neural networks and natural language
processing to generate alpha signals the
nanodegree is like a laser it's focused
exactly on what you need today to
succeed
[Music]
you